on voit toutes les photos de groupe et
on réalise vraiment l'ampleur de la
situation qui on voit que ça comme juste
et simple fait divers mais comme un
phénomène
elles sont devenues de triste symbole
l'emblème d'une cruelle indifférence qui
sont elles qu'est ce qui leur est arrivé
exactement et pourquoi un tel destin
ce sont des questions qui hantent toute
une génération d'autochtones c'est comme
important de parler toute sa puissance
que j'entendais ce du victime voulait y
met en avant les facteurs puis des
projets qui ressortira ans ont disparu
parce qu'il fait une fugue ou parce que
tyco dès qu'elle prend une consommation
oui dia la rivière n'en peut plus des
stéréotypes
elle connaît les faits elle organise des
conférences beau depuis des années au
nom de celles qui sont disparus pour
elle une enquête publique c'est avant
tout un devoir collectif de démontrer la
responsabilité de demandes derrière soi
une grand public le gouvernement les
autorités concert des services sociaux
et de santé d'exploser et d'entendre une
fois pour toutes le calvaire de milliers
de femmes qui vivent au canada dans
l'insécurité la violence et la pauvreté
dans quel public pour sa génération
c'est le droit d'espérer mu pour la
prochaine idée de m'imaginer que d'avoir
une fille autochtone puis quand flamand
avait alors trois fois plus de risques
d'être victime d'un acte de violence qu
un apporteur de fait c'est comme ça fait
peur mélissa mollen du puits elle aussi
une militante a donné naissance à sa
fille il y a trois mois moi je suis dans
une urgence présentement m'assurer que
ma fille qu'on va pouvoir bouger marcher
sans moelle à l'école aller dans la
ville vivent dans les communautés alors
a pas de mots clés si c'est personnel
elle qui a été de toutes les
manifestations pour exiger des réponses
se prépare à de dures révélations ça
reste que ça va c'est pas on n'annonce
pas une fight on annonce le dévoilement
pas d'une situation qui va être plus
heureux que beaucoup de canadiens
s'attendent à voir au roi en temps il
faudra du temps beaucoup de temps pour
tout comprendre avant même de voir une
seule recommandation mais pour carole
lévesque le premier pas est important
les autochtones sont d'emblée d'un coup
dès le début et ça c'est un signe d'un
changement qu'on n'avait pas vu depuis
une bonne dizaine d'années et pour ces
femmes comme mélissa et oui dia qui
revendique une justice depuis dix ans
dans la rue jour et nuit
le message est clair le rôle du
politique c'est de nous enlever ce
fardeau de prouver que la vie d'une
femme autochtone est tout aussi
importante que celle des autres
et si thammarat altérer ce que radio
canada montréal